inspired Spotify then what was the
challenge there well the challenge was
so actually if you kind of fast-forward
I ended up accidentally starting a few
of those companies like a web hosting
company following a web design company
at a time my thoughts you know this
company Google sounded pretty cool this
is back in 1998 so I applied for a job
there and they kind of said hey come
back when you have a college degree so I
said screw them I'm gonna build a better
search engine can't be that hard right
that actually did turn out to be really
hard yeah so and I took a lot of the
money I had in this web design thing and
tried to pour it into that and lost it
all got it what happened when you
started the rocket ship company yeah but
it falls into that same category which
is I think Elon didn't actually know
fully exactly how hard the rocket ship
become right baby right until he started
putting them up right and and I think
that there's something like if people
would know all the you know there's
something said about that the
entrepreneurs that are successful in an
industry or seldom the people with the
best knowledge about it it's usually
either outsiders or people that have
somewhat of an insight but but aren't
like full deep in into the weeds of why
things are working the way they are
because then most people just wouldn't
be doing what they're doing it's it can
become too daunting because you've heard
all the reasons why it wouldn't work I
mean let's face it Spotify was not the
first right online streaming service or
online music service right
I guess Pandora was or and then before
that Rhapsody maybe Rhapsody was
actually way before way before yeah
they kind of took a lot of arrows yeah
coming up the hill yeah when did you
come up with the idea of Spotify was
there a specific moment we you said like
we're have the fewer people constructed
a founder story the PR people definitely
constructed the founders story by now
you know but but that's a real story
yeah yeah the the truth story is
you know I that I I came to the point
where I ended up selling some companies
in the end almost going into bankruptcy
but then managed to turn things around
and then sold the company ended up you
know thinking about what I wanted to do
with my life
and my co-founder marked and actually
ended up selling or IPO in his company
which is trade obler roughly at the same
time so we were sitting in my apartment
in suburban southern Stockholm and we
were just brainstorming what we wanted
to do and what was important to us and
actually ever since Napster the first
thing that was what got me into that I
knew that I wanted to be working with
the Internet
oh really you downloaded Napster and you
were like yes thing is phenomenal yeah
it's just phenomenal because I mean back
then the web was really just text right
best there was some gift animation the
like a funny rabbit or something but
it's a blue dot yeah yeah exactly but
but you know it just wasn't very
exciting and then all of a sudden with
when Napster it was really the first
service that the show that the internet
was for more than just text and images
it was really like a multimedia thing so
for me I I i just realized at that
moment like holy [ __ ] this is what I
want to do this is this is going to be
the next big thing and so I came back to
that um you know really thinking about
it if Napster was the first thing that
got me in an entity in and that's how is
that the music just hasn't been solved
and we started talking about it because
it was so obvious that from the consumer
endpoint this is how people wanted to
consume music they wanted to listen to
more music than ever before they wanted
to discover new artists integrated mass
they loved having it you know on demand
in the sense of I mean back then it took
a few minutes to download the song but
he still felt a lot better than
going out driving in your car going to
Tower Records picking out the this stuff
so you know it was just a really really
really fundamentally broken thing
because for the first thing you had the
consumer thing and the consumer thing
was actually working but it was the
business model that ended up being the
problem it wasn't that people didn't
love Napster or Kazan right or even
Travis's first companies Scour yeah I
mean it's very interesting when you
think about it Travis did scour yep red
swoosh uber yep and they have Nicholas
who did cuz uh yep
the video service in between and the sky
was the video service in between being
really big and it didn't work yeah we'll
ask him about it yeah when he comes out
what was that failure that you had
between Skype and Kazaa it was like the
one that got you sued then there was the
one that failed and then there was one
that was you J yeah well ask him yeah
courts always appreciate that yeah
always focus in on the failure oh so you
decide you want to go for Spotify yeah
and what's next did you just build a
prototype or an interface or did you
yeah we started building the product oh
well that's that's always what came
first for us this just like and and the
original vision was like imagine you
know we were iTunes users so imagine
having iTunes but but having all the
world's music in your music library and
it and I was really sort of attached to
this emotional sense what would that do
to your behavior if you had all of the
world's music on your hard drive and
today we take that thing for granted but
back then you know as I said it took a
couple of minutes for you to download
just one song so we needed to create
that feeling about you know immediacy of
no buffering no nothing it just needed
to be lightning-fast so that it felt
like you had all the most music on your
hardware and in fact in that timeframe
people talked about the digital jukebox
in the sky before the term cloud existed
right and people said you know really
the holy grail is this digital jukebox
in the sky where you could have anything
you want at any time right isn't it
amazing it's here now yes it is amazing
but you know what's interesting about
Sweden is it it was here for a long time
not just because of Spotify but the
truth is we had these broadband
connections that enabled us like you
know actually yes they are got gigabit
fiber pulled into my house I hate you
man yes thank you I knew that from
behalf of all Americans yes we hate all
of you yes for your gigabyte and also
everybody in South Korea we hate as well
yeah let me get you're paying $30 a
month for this so I am we're hanging 149
Swedish crowns which is less than 20
bucks a month now I might punch you in
the face you're paying $20 for a gigabit
yeah I mean what are you paying for in
Brooklyn I think you get three megabit
for $85 from Time Warner yeah yeah yeah
it's basically like you pay your rent
then you pay for your internet and then
your card your kids tuition yeah yeah
something like that so when did you what
was your plan to deal with the licensing
what because you did mention like hey
the interface kind of worked yeah and
then Napster wasn't perfect but they did
kind of get close yeah well so I wasn't
very sophisticated and in terms of what
the plan was to tackle that so the
original plan was like well I guess it
will take about six months to get the
licensing down reasonable yeah you know
somebody in Hollywood in charge yeah and
and sure we'll have to pay some money
but I mean their business is going like
this anyway so I'm sure that they'll
just want to get the music out there to
as many people as possible and we'll
figure out a way to deal with it later
once we get the scale either through
advertising or getting people to pay
somehow we truly were naive yes